foreign
is uh roughly speaking a civilizational
term rather than a political concept
and it has very little Unity which in
certain circumstances is a is an
advantage rather than disadvantage but
the interests of the countries that make
it up as you no doubt have noticed
recently are are very uh different and
sometimes conflicting
moreover there's disagreement not only
uh between countries but within
countries themselves and I think we're
living in a time in with in which uh
political legitimacy has been lost not
least in our own country but also in
countries like France
um we secondly we live at a time when
Pop populations value comfort and
consumption more than anything else and
I'm not observing myself from these
strictures I quite like Comfort myself
but these are this is not a very uh
advantageous auspicious circumstance
from which to demand sacrifices from a
population and we supposedly sympathize
very deeply with the Ukraine but I
wonder how far that sympathy will go uh
if the lights go out and there's no
Heating and so on how long that sympathy
will last
um
third the idea that the West is or could
have been a hegemon forever is nonsense
in my view
since the organized systematic and
institutionalized testing of nature
known as science it's a completely
Western
invention but it is universal
and it was a
in my view inevitable that other nations
other peoples would catch up and a good
example of that is Japan after the
arrival of Commodore Perry it was
amazing how quickly actually it caught
up fourth perhaps some kind of
existential crisis would bring us all
together but the chances of that
happening before it is too late I think
a rather small it will be Five Minutes
to Midnight at the latest and I don't
think we are there now I don't think we
believe actually that we're in an
existential crisis
uh fifth we were asked whether conflict
uh in the 20 if there will be a serious
conflict in the 20th century and a 21st
century and if the path three Millennia
are anything to go by the answer is yes
um I hope the answer is no but I think
the answer is yes because we are
conflictual animals and finally let me
recommend to you if you don't know the
play by Max Frisch uh the fire raisers
let me recommend that to you as a
wonderful metaphorical
exploration of our current situation uh
which of course he rose about 60 or 70
years ago but is a wonderful a wonderful
play which will illuminate our current
situation thank you very much Tulip is
the age of the West now truly over
thanks very much
I was thinking about this on the way and
on the train over here and what I would
say is that I was looking at the way the
West reacted sorry to the invasion of
Ukraine by Putin I have to say I saw the
West reacting in a way that is in a very
coordinated fashion and whether that was
supplying Medical Aid whether that was
arms whether that was ammunition whether
it was an anti-tank whether that was
collecting refugees and I say collecting
because the government didn't do much it
was individual people looking on
websites finding people and then housing
refugees and as a constituency MP I've
seen a lot of work in that I saw the
West pulling together in a fashion that
I haven't seen for a long time and I
don't I think when Putin invaded Ukraine
in the bloody manner that he did he
expected a lot more disunity so for me
without sounding like I'm always so
optimistic I actually did see the West
pulling to together and I did see them
reacting in a way that Putin probably
didn't expect
president macron in 29 2019 described
NATO as brain dead but I think at this
point if you think about the way the
NATO alliance is working I think it'd be
very hard to question the integrity and
effectiveness of what NATO has been
doing and all the people working
together I think it's had a bit of a
rebirth actually in the offer effects of
what's happened in the war
and I hope countries like Finland who
are applying to join it they do get
their application and accepted but I'm
not naive I don't think just because we
reacted well and better than I expected
in the aftermath of the war or during
the war it doesn't mean that we've
kind of reached every conclusion we
could and everything's fine I think what
NATO has to do now and we need to look
at this is we need to look at how it
stops from becoming a crisis management
Alliance to actually responding to
whatever the next invasion is because I
think they probably will be another
Invasion by Putin obviously we don't
know what it is but it also needs to
look at the military assistance
that it can give to Ukraine as we move
forwards and of course we've got to look
at the cuts of the British army we've
got to look at how we defend ourselves
but I think if we strengthen the
relationships we have in the NATO
alliance and if we look at how we can
work together I don't feel as dismal as
people are making it out to be about the
West being in Decline I think there's a
lot of good relationships that are being
created I think we're doing a lot of
good work
um most recently we were in Parliament
when the Ukrainian leader zelenski
addressed us and it was a historic
moment to be in Parliament with him
hiding in a bunker basically and telling
us what's happening in this country
looking like a man who has lived through
a war talking about what had happened to
the children to the grandmothers who are
trying to escape to babies to women who
are suffering war crimes and he talked
about how much his allies and how much
support he had received from people in
the west and he thanked the Prime
Minister and many of you will know I'm
not a fan of the Prime Minister but he
thanks the Prime Minister he thanked the
United Kingdom and he said it was the
Allies who were supporting him and
that's how we're going to reach the end
of the war is if we all support solensky
and Ukraine so for me in a way I'm
looking at the West I'm looking at
countries like Germany who were a bit um
hesitant about putting sanctions on
Russia who have now tried to stop their
Reliance on oil and gas from Russia so I
think there is a movement from the West
to pull together when one of us is being
attacked so I'm a bit more optimistic
it's not usual for politicians to be
like that but I feel a bit more
optimistic about the West we welcome it
thank you tulip Nigel is the age of the
West now truly over well
um I think the first thing to say is
that the West's uh global domination if
you look at this uh across you know the
long durray of History
um goes as they say in match of the day
against the Run of play because we
really only imposed ourselves on and
shaped of the institutions of the modern
world from the late 18th century in the
19th century
um and if you look at
most of history there were two countries
India and China that between them
accounted for about 50 percent of the
world's total global economic activity
it's hardly surprising uh given all the
things that have happened in the interim
that you know this equation is
rebalancing itself and that we're seeing
a shift of power from west to east you
know this this is uh
you know this is not something we should
be surprised at Chinese leaders are fond
of saying these days the East is rising
the West is in Decline and as with
everything to do with the Chinese
Communist Party they're sort of half
right there's no question that there is
this transport fur is taking place but
and this is the important thing this is
not a zero-sum game the fact that
countries like China India countries of
Southeast Asia Japan uh South Korea are
you know gaining ground you know
becoming more prosperous becoming more
globally influential does not
necessarily mean that the West you know
suddenly you know gets canceled out
um I was very interested to read this
morning
um a piece by a gentleman
uh by the name of Professor wanky so who
is China's foremost American expert and
he made the point that you know we can
conclude that the United States
is in Decline when we no longer see long
queues
of people outside American consulates
wanting to study their work there live
there yeah
um so that's Point number one point
number two
um we are unquestionably moving
um into from a period of relative low
entropy after the end of the Cold War
into a period of high entropy you know
no question about that it may not seem
that way if you live in Afghanistan Iraq
Yemen or the Democratic Republic of
Congo but generally speaking during the
1990s and 2000s globally we were able to
actually build institutions reinforce
organizations and now we're seeing that
process moving somewhat into reverse
we've probably hit Peak globalization
but this is not to say this is the end
of globalization I think it's more of
that globalization henceforth will take
on a different character from what it
has had
um and you know finally you know in
relation to the West I would say
essentially we have enjoyed a kind of
40-year holiday from geopolitics and
that holiday is now coming to an end and
we are having to rethink some long-held
assumptions about you know the validity
of an approach that is based on soft
power on economics which is very much
what the European Union is all about and
coming to terms with the reality that
state on state conflict is back the the
security threats we've had to deal with
up until now have largely been
um posed by non-state actors but that is
now shifting and you know we're back in
the game
um I think the the performance of the
Russian military
um in Ukraine demonstrated that they're
much vaunted military modernization was
in many ways a potomkin exercise you
know lots of nice facades but not much
going on behind it and the river came to
a straight con address between NATO and
Russia Russia would clearly lose we
should take comfort from that but at the
same time
um I think we do need to learn some
lessons and we'd rather Loft sight of
the fact that I never know who said this
that the you know the price of peace is
eternal vigilance we do need as tulip
said to to
re-invest in security capabilities I say
this with feeling because in the decade
at the end of the Cold War my former
organization was cut by 25 such that
when real problems kicked off in the
early 2000s we were simply not manned or
equipped to deal with them as we would
wish so I think we need to invest in
these capabilities the business
Community are slowly and painfully
coming to terms with the reality that
powerful though they are politics to
continue watching this video click the
link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas